my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them subway
in the middle of this video hello
everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today we are doing another
q a this one is for gaming i also do
ones that are personal which is mostly
like tv and movies and stuff you can
leave questions for either of them below
and i will just pull them into the right
video going forward thanks said hello
lana what would be your favorite quest
in any game on any platform oh man
um
i've forgotten the name of it but i
really love the quest in the witcher 3
where you get drunk such a fan of that
there's also uh one particular um
mission i guess they they're called in
red dead redemption 2
that
is sort of a spoiler but um
been doing like a tiny bit of
songwriting lately and i wrote a song
about it because it like affected me so
deeply it's the one where the the song
that they wrote for
uh red dead plays that like may i
stand and shaken
by d'angelo i think that song is
that song as you're writing back to a
house um
to one of the settlements just like
affected me to my core in such a
specific way because of the context i
really love that bunch of quests in mass
effect 2 that i think are incredible man
my head's going like 100 miles an hour
there are so many it's hard to name them
but um i'll give a shout out to that
drunk quest in in the witcher 3 i
thought it was fantastic especially
because of the timing that it happens in
that game is like
almost a moment of peace in between two
massive conflicts um where you know what
you're headed towards and it's just like
a moment of levity really really loved
it
47 mason said how do you feel about the
horizon forbidden west review scores did
it go higher or lower than you expected
i actually don't know let's take a look
um at the metacritic shall we so we pull
up the metacritic i'm really excited
about this game for the record i think
this game looks really good i'm stoked
about it um okay so metascore right now
is an 89 summary
join eloy as she braves the forbidden
west a majestic but dangerous frontier
that conceals mysterious new threats
explore distant lands
fight bigger and more orange or
ah they say aw americans say ah
fight bigger and more awe-inspiring
machines and encounter astonishing new
tribes as you return to the far future
post-apocalyptic world of horizon we got
a couple of hunnids gaming bolt twin
fennet playstation universe at 95 screen
right 90 ign italia when it where's
actual ign
game informers in 93
verizon forbidden west reaches a new bar
for gorilla games it does more than
surpass its predecessor it takes
horizon's fiction to captivating places
and builds a rich world the well does
look very very very good to me
easy ally is given a 90
ign is a 90 a tr a triumphant
combination of enthralling combat
top-tier creature and character design
in a captivating open world horizon
forbidden west is an absolute blast and
a fantastic showcase for the power of
the ps5 survivor
who wrote that i know who's divira
um
it's job gilroy no way
that's funny okay so um
survivor is an australian website run by
steve he's a
wonderful human um in my experience
someone that i know from when i was
working in the australian games industry
um i think i've mentioned steve on
podcast before as like he has a job he
runs a website he has a boyfriend
and
still manages to just have
so much gamer score i just don't know
how he does it incredible um joe gilroy
though you know is obviously not steve
the owner of survivor job gilroy
was the person who first paid me to
write a review
i believe
it was game arena and it was my first
review which was uh what's the name of
the game it was this platformer i don't
know what it was called
and i don't think the website even
exists anymore but it was job gilroy who
also controversially um gave i think
halo 4 away lower score than usual on
metacritic and wrote the doom 2016
review for ign
yeah also joe gilroy
which was a very controversial one even
people who worked at ign because it was
a seven out of ten
seven point one um the internet was very
upset about it but people at ign were
also like i don't agree with that at all
the game's amazing so he's often an
outlier um but for the record it's in a
way that i think is like interesting and
valuable i'd way prefer to read a bunch
of different opinions in in reviews than
for everyone to say the exact same thing
um
happy to read his stuff but it is also
funny to me to see that it's joke gilroy
a grand glorious world and only one real
way to tackle it oh my guess is he's
saying it's like limited or something
also i'm sorry if you can
hear this sweet baby chewing on a toy in
the background over there i will not
take it off her for the purposes of the
internet you will just have to deal with
it this is largely pretty positive to
start with
everyone keeps mentioning like finding
the open world really really beautiful
um and the underwater stuff
it looks it's best when you dive
underwater zero dawn restricted alloys
aquatic adventures to a little more than
a duck and cover effort but in the
sequel she's free as a bird an
underwater bird
very nice yeah i'm definitely excited
for the newman of water stuff also i
keep seeing people on twitter say that
the climbing is really cool
and they've upgraded that in an
interesting way things
too often feel claustrophobic
don't get me wrong everything i said
about the open world is true you can go
wherever you want
confines and context of the game feel so
narrow as to be overbearing that's
interesting
criticizes the climbing
reduces boulder into a tedious act of
obligation instead of the thrilling
excursion even before interesting um it
seems like yeah seems like most of the
reviews are really positive uh overall
obviously with an 89 meter score i'm
super excited about this game
um it seems like job's criticisms were
or survivor's criticisms i suppose were
related to feeling like some things were
limited or a bit restrictive for their
liking but interestingly enough and this
is pretty unusual i actually believe the
original horizon also got an 89 this
will change over the coming days as more
people add it up and i mean it's review
scores don't matter it doesn't who cares
you know it doesn't it's not some
definitive number you can you can score
it however you please
but i think
the original it did the original also
got an 89 and i feel like that's pretty
uncommon
that you see a sequel and and the first
iteration get
the exact same score it's gonna be
pretty unlikely
huh yeah i'm super excited to play it
though i'm really really looking forward
to it um i'm getting through sifu at a
steady pace
so that's what i planned to do was like
i knew i was never going to finish dying
light 2 because it sounds like it's too
long and played a bunch of dying light
too i am going to finish sifu
i want to do it before the patch comes
out that makes the game easier and then
i should have elden ring very soon
and i'm going to smash through that and
then
play horizon last this month is like my
order so i'll probably like play the
first hour of verizon on the 18th when
the game comes out do the first hour for
youtube like i normally do but then i
think i'll actually mostly play horizon
in march that'll be like next month
because
who could get through all these games
it's too many games it is time to talk
about keeps keeps is a subscription
service that focuses on making it easier
and more affordable for men to treat
their male pattern baldness online did
you know that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldus by the time they're 35 and the
best way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
hair left because there is no magic cure
for boldness but you can prevent hair
loss from happening in the first place
with keeps you will get the fda approved
doctor recommended plan that is right
for you without even having to leave
your couch a licensed doctor will review
your information online and recommend
the right hair loss treatment plan for
you then your treatment is shipped
directly to your door every three months
at half the cost of a pharmacy because
they offer generic versions of all the
fda approved medications for hair loss
from there if you have any questions or
concerns you can message your keeps
doctor 24 7 and track your progress with
keepsa's progress tracking tool hair
loss stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com
appears or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash elana pierce
archangel said hey elena do you prefer a
game better when you can play as a
female protagonist you wish more games
had the option or does it not make a
difference
uh i've never really had a preference i
actually majority of the time if i have
a character creator will pick a male
character
um
always have just preferred to play as a
male versus a female
if i'm role playing or it's like a
fantasy world for some reason but there
are certainly like female characters
that i love exponentially more that i
feel like i love the male characters
like
i love ayani from dead or alive and
ninja gaiden um i love jade from beyond
good and evil big fan of joanna dog from
perfect dark
i feel like surely the coalition is too
far along
with um
the voice for that game but listen if i
can i please just just let me audition
to play joanna okay if anyone from the
coalition is watching okay
i can do it there's i can't do all kinds
of voice acting i'm definitely getting
better all right but i there's some of
it that i suck at you know what i can do
a kind of stoic british woman let me
look up some joanna dark lines all right
you ready we've got some voice lines
here okay so i'm gonna try and do joanna
dark i feel like my perspective is
she's like a little bit bondy um we're
just discounting perfect dark zero
because i really didn't like her
performance in perfect dark zero i feel
like they made her american i think i
prefer the the bond like
british woman okay
um
let's do this one daniel carrington ah
carrington how good's perfect dark how
did we get here what was the question
anybody asked me i don't remember am i
ready
what do you mean i was ready half an
hour ago it's you that's holding us up
they should keep you away from mirrors
joanna meets the president who are you
young lady joanna looks at the
president's picture frame
mr president
you're in danger
trent is trying to kidnap you you can't
make accusations like that without
evidence i assume that you have some
that's how the president sounds to me
naturally always as an american
this is a recording of a meeting between
trent and the other conspirators well
that seemed overwhelming i'm in your
hand what do we do now
nailed it nailed it let me play joanna
doc that's all i'm saying okay oh yeah
we were talking about uh
female protagonist yeah those are uh
some of my favorites um and i but i have
no preference for it like if it's if i
don't like the character i don't like
the character like if it's a female
character and i don't care about them
it doesn't add anything to me at all
yeah it's just generally not a huge deal
to me kevin asked how do you feel about
the fact that some playstation games are
repeating animations from their last gen
games to their ps5 games
oh my gosh okay
um
so this is a reference i assume
to a couple of tweets that have gotten a
lot of attention from i don't remember
the name of the account or anything
maybe it's multiple people i don't know
that have like clipped out
some gifs
uh or clipped out gameplay and turned
them into gifs and then just everybody
shares them like crazy it just very
clearly seems like it's a troll to me
and that we don't need to be giving this
attention because it's silly but some
people do fall for it so
ultimately there would be no reason to
change an animation
of a character doing a certain thing you
don't change the way that you do
something after five years you will
still stand up the same way in a lot of
cases especially if you haven't like
aged dramatically why why would it
change um so it logically doesn't make
any sense but it's more so that
reusing animations is not a copy-paste
system it doesn't work that way but it
is more efficient if you want the games
to be good in other ways and have new
things in other ways like in ways that
actually matter like adding more
animations or
a bigger open world or a million other
things that you would want from a sequel
you want teams to be able to reuse
things where it makes sense rebuilding
that entirely where it doesn't add
anything to the actual gamer who's
probably not even going to remember the
way that animation looked
unless you put the two games side by
side is just really inefficient and
would result in worse games overall like
that would be a bad use of time bad work
ethic very inefficient game development
in a way that would just like hurt video
games because it's not lazy it still
takes
a very long time to make a game um
it's just if that one thing
makes sense to remain the same
then it would it's the smart thing to do
that is better for the project overall
essentially president [ __ ] said if you
ever wrote a silent hill game do you
think you could top the second one i'm
assuming i don't actually remember i'm
assuming that i spoke about in my last
gaming q a
about how if i were ever to write for
anything other than like i always say
sms i love writing for and i will stay
at sms for a long time i would otherwise
go to rockstar
or
kojima getting a silent hill game
oh boy i would be there i would be there
that would like i would lose my mind
over that
um do i think i could top the second one
no
no who am i to say that i think that i
could top anything i'm i'm still really
learning um that's what i feel like i
try to spend most of my time doing is
just learning there's no universe in
which i would say that i think that i
can do better than like what i think is
one of the best uh stories in any horror
game ever but it would be a great time i
would definitely enjoy it the sandman 94
gaming said would you be getting the
psvr too discounted as a sony developer
or will you have to pay full price for
it um
we get discounts on a lot of stuff at
sony i get a lot of merch discounted i
get um they also send us a lot of stuff
they send us a lot of gifts which is
really cool they're like the only
company i've ever worked for that does
that it's super neat and i believe that
some people got ps vibes uh as long as
you were working for sony when it came
out um i don't really know what the
rules were because i started like two
weeks after it came out but uh working
at sony is also the reason that i can no
longer get early access to
playstation games so uh they don't give
me any early game codes anymore
so i can't play like horizon early um i
have to play that the same time everyone
else does basically i won't get any uh
any sony games early or be able to play
them or stream them early um i wasn't
able to with ratchet and clank basically
just have to play them at the same time
as everyone else and buy them for full
price too i don't get uh sony games for
free either which obviously i am fine
with but it is something that like
console fanboys
definitely get confused about i've had
people criticize me for like not
tweeting about playstation games enough
from my perspective playstation would
prefer it and again this is just how i
see it i feel like they would prefer it
if i never spoke about playstation at
all they don't care if they talk about
xbox and nintendo i could do that as
much as i like
but the minute that i talk about
anything playstation publicly positively
or negatively it like has to be
something they consider in a pr cycle or
marketing cycle or whatever it's
something that they then have to think
about so very backwards thing that the
console fanboys have is um i think sony
would prefer that i talk about xbox and
nintendo than that i talk about
playstation
in general but obviously completely okay
with that i absolutely love working
there i love what i get to do and
it doesn't it doesn't matter making
youtube videos isn't my day job i mean
whether that's more than what you asked
i just thought that i would give the
full detail there and i think i'm gonna
leave it there everybody thank you for
the questions i hope that you're all
having
a wonderful february it's valentine's
day today so happy valentine's day if
you are celebrating it with your loved
ones or by yourself you do you thank you
keeps sponsoring this video you can
check out the link in description and i
will see you guys next time bye